bootleg cat podcast special guest in
here I met this kid a couple of weeks
ago in Vallejo California I was at the
Russell's house and you opened for the
Russell in his backyard and I remember
texting the Russell in the middle of
your performing I'm like yo who is this
kid on stage because you was like giving
me goosebumps bro you killed it man so I
was like yo I got you got off stage I
found out your your actual child
how old are you I'm 16. 16 years old I
chopped it up with your pops and I was
like you gotta bring them out to LA so
we're just gonna have to first of all
introduce yourself my name is Molly I am
from Merced California Merced stand up
shout out to Merced uh what's your IG my
ideas the real Mali d-a dot real Mali
that's me
m-i-a-m-a-l-i-m-a-l-i yep let's go run
that we're just gonna have him get to it
man let's get to it let's get to it oh
16 years old ladies and gentlemen 16
years old Shadow Merced
Mercedes what's going on baby
Legends on this we got a wrist
all right yeah it's Molly
let's go
listen
they've been trying to play me such a
baby I'm used to it only choice to treat
me like a mode and not new to it cause
if it's a youngin that's doing better
than you doing that lead too much space
for old [ __ ] to get they move on and
we don't know what they want to fight
for but I don't care I flipped the
switch for nothing like the light broke
walking on a tightrope tiptoeing my eyes
closed no backbone fixing you need to
see a chiropractor no more captain no
more acting in the Rapture rapping you
not active [ __ ] they say if I like them
then I get the cheese but if I rap like
Molly these [ __ ] is gonna remember me
pop it out my shoulders if you really
feel like you killing me never break the
code if you really feel like a friend of
me for real cause there's some things
that you don't do the whole [ __ ] doing
the whole things that I won't do cold
when I go through bars they should have
told you I spit they like oh my God I'm
glad I know you whole team been banking
on me to blow so I say I meet you at the
top but I'm a cold dude I keep my green
at the crib like it's Whole Foods I'm on
top like the Lakers back in no two they
say ain't no you but do they really know
you for real when you on what they gonna
do far back in NBA when I drop they
feeling like the gas tank empty I can't
lie and tell you that the cash stay with
me but I know I'm the truth so I ain't
worried they with me see the shoes they
fit me I could run a couple of miles on
them change the hardwood floor them
while we're tiling them and I know I'm
way too young to throw the tile in so I
take my Ellen spin right back around
[ __ ] uh what's left [ __ ] the whole
city Norm next [ __ ] I say thank you
then I'm worried about what's next
[ __ ] seem like these [ __ ] want a
blue check waiting what an actual check
[ __ ] you better check it's the baby boy
no Jody I'm different though Two Chains
I do things like chess like chicken I
move Lanes a real Trailblazer my [ __ ]
the new Dame the same with my shots if I
shoot it it's gonna drop on like boy out
here taking fans I'm a hot boy I'm the
closer [ __ ] get some some like a top
boy something like a lid close to my
heart like a rib that's what I deserve
for what I did that's the most so let's
make a toast since I'm a kid it can't be
no alcohol my [ __ ] we got a ball I'm 10
toes down I get it with all of y'all but
I'm not really worried I'm better than
all of y'all that's the young ones grown
ones no ones old ones who I'm worried
about let them know no one cause ain't
nobody finna stop me [ __ ] and imma keep
sending shots walkie-talkie hope you
copy [ __ ] the hottest rap out I feel
like Wayne when he was just a little
baby rapping in the South and everybody
saying I'm gonna get us out I caught a
Babe Ruth a name believe me until I hit
it out hopefully they get it now but
they understand me like I'm about to
have a baby I ain't got no plan B
hopefully my family is supported with my
plan B trying to grab the youth and show
them something that you can be you could
be a teacher you can be a lawyer you
ain't gotta be Street you will build a
destroyer for real all you gotta do is
put it to work and some leave it in mind
but me I put it to a versus smelly yeah
oh
wow
hey would you mind uh when I saw you uh
performing in Vallejo you were doing a
record I think it's when I told you
about Apple would you mind doing your
verses from that record acapella real
quick it is good what's the name of the
song just so free for people to go check
it out and all that uh name is her cry
by Molly is on all streaming platforms
so can we do those verses acapella I I
don't I hope you don't mind doing that
for them we gotta let people know man
they gotta feel this [ __ ] like I fell
through it man let's go come on come on
all right listen
uh my homie asked me why she blacking in
the lungs maybe it's that pain from all
this trauma in the slums look at how
they raised this in the bottom with no
love building little screws were never
taught to tighten up now I feel like I'm
the one to make it out of this
predicament and win so they want to sit
in that room but they don't never let us
in it's gonna be me and mine forever
I'll be rocking with my kid up in this
city where these [ __ ] knock down like
half of my friends when they label this
as devilish nah that ain't really fair
but I could smell it in the air I know
my whole city Heavens talking to the
privilege I'm just hoping that they
getting it if they can't help us out
ain't relevant speaking to their song
trying to help them see the vision hard
to get that point across if they ain't
been locked in these trenches we lucky
if our daddies ain't dead or riding in
prison then your mom ain't got the time
you can't even pay him no visit when you
grow up way too fast and need a plan
when Mama teach you how to be a man and
maybe you'll understand see my [ __ ]
moving out since pounds in them grams
cause that's all us young [ __ ] ever
saw up in advance when you sitting in
them bleaches watching Trappers reach
them bass like a [ __ ] think it's his
trying to get up out of them stairs tell
them Shackles on your hands and you see
what it's really about and praying for
no bands now you praying to make it out
for real it's remember nice you can't
step without a gun on you like watch out
because them [ __ ] will go dumb on you
Mama crying to this [ __ ] cause it's done
for you pull it out [ __ ] it back lay the
drum on you I ain't hopping to it cause
I knew it ain't for me luckily I had the
choice most didn't have the luxury
thankfully Pop came back with everything
that he's done for me that kicked in the
dough six years old they had a gun on me
pastor always selling hope young [ __ ]
selling dope they both giving Visions
which one's more addicting I don't know
constant flashbacks I never knew the
knights in hell was cold your Shack was
Titan when you pop that [ __ ] Spa
getting both Penn had to hold a possible
now when they let them go this is Henry
and them jobs ain't hitting so you
sending O's really they try not to teach
us different so we didn't know notice
that everything would be different if we
didn't blow wow man it's really wow so
there's so much harder when you started
from the ground and then when you down
ain't none of your [ __ ] around this
homies rather die but they was just some
clams they can hear them so we use the
gun to make it sound now he all up in
that court for Life he's gonna be locked
down you don't see it though
I'm always asking why you keep a gun
cause I can get a lawyer you can't get
another son I told me keep your head up
through your problems never run I know
you had some hard times but there'll be
more to come so if them tears dropping
let them flow don't be ashamed like
being scars and you could let them show
yeah
hey man shout out your IG man uh I'm the
real Molly on igda dot real Mali m-a-l-i
you have music out I got music out right
now I got two EPS out right now one name
it's Mali on all streaming platforms the
other one named Tony also on all
streaming platforms I got one coming
soon called now it's undeniable so keep
y'all hey thank you for coming through
bro thank you yes sir 16 years old
ladies and gentlemen that was incredible
bro thank you
that was flower
I know you just watched the crazy
freestyle we got another one coming next
week presented to you by LRG don't
forget to use my promo code at
l-r-g.com go to their website it's in
the description below and use the promo
code bootleg you'll save 30 off and they
just drop these look at these basketball
shorts boys these things are crazy you
know what I'm saying lrg's [ __ ] back
so why don't you go ahead and uh go get
you some 30 off right now I know you
just watched the crazy freestyle we got
another one coming next week presented
to you by LRG don't forget to use my
promo code at
l-r-g.com go to their website it's in
the description below and use the promo
code bootleg you'll save 30 off and they
just drop these look at these basketball
shorts boys these things is crazy you
know what I'm saying lrg's [ __ ] back
so why don't you go ahead and uh go get
you something 30 off right now